after a year of lockdowns due to covid
multiple stimulus checks
and pent-up demand spring break is in
full effect in miami south beach
so we hit the streets to find out how
people are funding their vacation
was this paid for with savings put on a
credit card or did that stimmy pay for
it
let's talk money all we talk is money
all we talk is money
all we talk is money we're here in south
beach ladies where are you in town from
charlotte north carolina charlotte all
of you uh new york new jersey i'm from
iowa
las vegas new york san diego california
baby in the house
philly what brings you to south beach
i'm just hearing a vacation you're
trying to party
birthday it's her birthday and we turn
into
god party you're here for the party
you're here on spring break you're here
spring break i'm a porn star so i came
to come shoot for the weekend
how about you ditto so we're two porn
stars
we're a married couple and we're just
trying to have a vacation get away from
the pandemic man
a lot of stuff going on so we're just
trying to vacation and
put some smiles on our face how are you
funding this trip are you paying cash
stimulus checks
we we're just fine so you got all right
i got paid to suck
you feel me so i like came and i'm now
i'm gonna drink it away
okay how about you i mean bartending
yeah
servers we're servers okay so you're
spending your tip money
i guess our income oh the casino bro
vegas after really uh having that money
they're trying to get lucky and uh
we're not getting lucky we are we do get
lucky we do wow poker players what's
going on uh these hands
shoot dice like no other wow i'm a
dancer you're a dancer
okay me too you're making money now
during the pandemic have you been able
to dance oh
oh oh i'll do construction um i'm a
surgical assistant so i make a lot of
money
so i don't really give a quick go right
so during the pandemic have you been
able to save more money have you
did you qualify for a stimulus check
nope i wish
no stimulus okay um i did
did you qualify for a stimulus check i
did but i never got it
are you gonna go try to get the bag or
what i'm gonna try to get it
did we i didn't get mine yeah did you
qualify for a stimulus check
yes i sure yeah okay you did that's not
what i spent
qualified what do you mean i got mine
how much
1400. how are you guys funding this
vacation
yeah sugar mama you haven't got the
first one expensive
this is not from a stimulus okay wow
that is that is not
this is not from a sugar daddy so you
got a stimulus check and you spent it on
this
yes nice you got 1400 i got 42.
40 200. how did you get so much i got i
got kids you got kids you got dependents
i got kids you got 4 200
butler okay and how much are you
spending on this trip 42
damn how much are we spending to be here
airbnb
was like five grand for the penthouse we
had a spaceship that was another three
grand
everybody every person would be looking
like what are they in like it was like
i'm seeing rolls royces lamborghini how
much did you spend to get down i don't
care i just spend money
you're a baller you're a baller alert
right here she's a baller
this is the baller this is the bro crew
biggest financial lesson during the
pandemic what do you got
save your money don't waste money on uh
small things
save that money try to invest discipline
discipline
discipline what kind of discipline i
would say like self-discipline
having to be inside all day kind of you
know organize me a little bit in my life
how about you save that money spend it
spend money
i see a lot of deaths in the hospital
every day so i live
like today is my last day i do save i do
invest
i do all of that but i also live like
hey i wake up this morning i could die
today and that's
that's it start a side hustle when
there's a pandemic try to
come up on top after the pandemic is
over invest
in crypto has the pandemic been a good
thing or a bad thing for you been a good
thing for me really i look at things as
positive so
respect you got to lose the win praise
god
and wait for blessing but but final the
final thing i got to say
assets and not liabilities if our guys
say stay down to you come up
and manifest the [ __ ] all right so i
interviewed a ton of people here in
south beach some people are here for
spring break some people are here
vacation and most people are here
for their birthday now what i understand
is this a lot of people are saying that
they saved up
money in order to come here and spend
that money on vacation
whether it was from their job saving
whether it was qualifying for a stimulus
check
people actually did save that money to
come here and have a good time
so the biggest lesson is if you save
that money you can spend it and enjoy
your time
so save that money